hey guys Ryan right here and today I'm
gonna be watching some movie clips of
Captain America the Winter Soldier
movies coming out tomorrow or in a few
hours from now actually and I am excited
to watch this movie already got my IMAX
tickets dead center seats Universal
CityWalk if you're gonna be there let me
know and we could talk anyway someone
asked that I watch this these clips a
long time ago never got around to it so
with my awesome timing I decided I'm
gonna watch it the day before it comes
out so here we go time to get pumped for
the movie that's coming out in just a
few hours from now alright first clip
it's called get me off the grid that's a
cool action line
[Music]
Sam Jackson man you don't want to [ __ ]
with that guy
[Music]
are the cops shooting at shields
that's right [ __ ] his ass up no one
shoots at Nick Fury
[Music]
look at it unleashing the theory
[Music]
that was pretty sweet calculating route
to secure location
people get so annoyed at me in the
theaters tomorrow
oh that's who he does that too
[Music]
Christmas soldier those cool shop I
didn't like the cars point of view
[Music]
where's cap when you need him good T's
got the chills going on I feel the
chills coming in anyway that was a good
clip because of the trailer I know he's
gonna make it out alive you know you see
him just hooked up to tubes and they're
like is he gonna make it so maybe he
dies still but I have a feeling Captain
America's gonna come in there and fight
the Winter Soldier next clip since we
got three of these to look at this one's
called
stand down cool ass titles
[Music]
hell yeah Captain America back on his
bike
good flex
tenorman's a terminator
I have [ __ ] shield man
oh [ __ ] you learned a future mastics
along the way
[Music]
nice
[Music]
yeah that shields just [ __ ]
everything up that's pretty cool
Captain America just took down an entire
jet mainly through flipping and throwing
that shield around this movie's gonna
rock my [ __ ]
all right last clip here we go what the
[ __ ] this one go let's see let's see
what this clip is all about no almost
got cast Nick I was cap losing to this
guy you can hit the shield and not feel
pain
[Music]
it's good thinking what weighted to the
personal Kia Oh Danny messed with the
wrong white boy he shouldn't have just
said that attacking a Captain America's
ego and [ __ ]
wha-oh
wanted to see the rest of that fight
anyway this has got me more pumped up
for the [ __ ] movie huh it's currently
at an 89 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
which is extremely good the consensus
says suspenseful and politically astute
Captain America the Winter Soldier is a
superior entry in the Avengers Canon is
sure to thrill Marvel diehards I'm
jacked up to see it everyone I know that
saw already [ __ ] loves it this is
gonna be one hell of a film and if
you're new to the channel
subscribe and speaking of subscribing
alright I do this fast as I gotta go
back to work Corey hood you're the [ __ ]
anytime you're in the LA area a few my
hood Corey don't really have a joke here
Germaine Flanagan dude I love the fact
that you keep watching our videos I
appreciate this you can't see this right
now but I'm rubbing my nipple for you
Myles Parkinson dude you're the [ __ ]
I've Skyped with you before had like a
45-minute conversation and you said ass
ruff
dude you sent me a message yesterday
that literally is just one of the best
compliments I've ever had you said
something along the lines of helped you
get through a rough time with these
videos that makes me feel so good
inspired me to just keep on going that's
why I'm here on my lunch break
yet again running late for work just so
I could thank you on camera and real
quick guys I did hey I know a movie
review that's up now and I really love
that movie I put the review up a little
late I know but it's one hell of a film
and it'd mean a lot if you guys actually
watch the review because I think it's
gonna be one of the top ten movies of
the year in terms of likability and then
after that get pumped for Captain
America the Winter Soldier Bible movie
Marvel movie put the two together
well then you got sin